Is it possible to eat too much salad?
Yeah, so everything is within balance with food here.
Well, we've discussed.
Can a person eat too much salad though?
So remember, in your three-ring binder,
there's a section that talks about your greens
and eating salads can be excellent for you.
But it depends on what you're choosing for your greens, for instance.
I really like kale and spinach.
So if I'm eating my salad with just kale and spinach
and I'm making kale and spinach smoothies and such,
kale and spinach have the most ability to increase nitric oxide,
which you necessarily don't want to do when you have a diagnosis of cancer
as excess nitric oxide is going to stimulate a vascular interthelial cell growth
and could increase the growth of a cancer.
So you don't want to be doing that.
Access salad if you're even eating leafy greens,
lettuces, arugula, things like that that aren't necessarily kale.
Could you eat too much of that?
Well, you are going to have a lot of methyl groups folate in foliage.
So yes, you could.
How much is too much?
I mean, I don't know.
I mean, if you're eating six salads a day on a regular basis,
then maybe you could.
Can anybody eat too much?
I don't know if you could possibly do that.
I have had patients in the past that came to me as strict vegans.
So I don't think that that lifestyle is necessarily healthy for most people
for lots of reasons.
But one of the reasons is you can get excess folate
and doing so too many methyl groups,
which is contradictory for a person with a diagnosis of cancer.
So you would have to be careful about that.
You can stimulate too much nitric oxide for a person with cancer.
So everything is within balance.
So I guess yes, you can eat too much salad.